[Musique]
c'était mi juin
des photographes de l' agence
france-presse immortalisé des libanais
devant leur frigo vide
des clichés qui montre le désespoir
jusqu'au désespoir ultime début juillet
devant un restaurant de la capitale
un homme a préféré en finir plutôt que
de lutter pour se nourrir
une autre sombre occasion pour les
libanais de manifester leur colère
comme ils le font depuis près d'un an la
société a énormément souffert ces
derniers mois explique cette
représentante de l'onu
en témoignent les longues files devant
les bureaux de change
les denrées de première nécessité qu'on
s'arrache maya terreau en sait quelque
chose elle a fondé au liban une
organisation pour distribuer de l'aide
alimentaire
elle a vu monter en flèche le nombre de
familles de la classe moyenne dans le
besoin
près d'un libanais sur deux s'est
endetté pour manger pour payer son loyer
on prévoyait un risque de famine pour
l'hiver directrice d'un centre de
réflexion stratégique basée à et c'était
avant les explosions
à l'épicentre de la déflagration ce
bâtiment blanc maintenant complètement
éventrées ce sont les silos à grains du
port de beyrouth 120 mille tonnes de
céréales inutilisable l'onu voit poindre
une pénurie de farine à très court terme
mais pas d'inquiétude a dit le ministre
de l'économie
il n'y aura aucun problème
d'approvisionnement ce qui laisse les
observateurs perplexes
à moins qu'ils aient des stocks cachés
ou des promesses de livraison les prix
des produits de base avait déjà doublé
entre septembre et mai le liban importe
80% de ces denrées et l transité en
majorité par le port aujourd'hui rayée
de la carte
la réorganisation des circuits fera
probablement monter les prix ouah ça
aide aussi comme en mai ce qui va
surtout monter c'est la colère devant
des conditions de vie devenue
insupportable
ici mathieu prost radio canada montréal